i'm kind of freaking out right now
because you're kind of my boss
so um but no what did fans miss at the
hallways panel who didn't show we didn't
go to that uh they missed the very first
look at what uh we'll be bringing to the
stream next year with ant-man a look at
what it looks like when aunt made a full
costume is this tall and jumps out to a
flying ad they missed paul douglas
michael douglas and paul rudd coming out
for the first time their very first trip
to comic con
and they missed almost the entire cast
of avengers age of ultron coming out on
on stage the one missing cast member was
scarlett johansson who provided a video
message for them and they missed the
very first look at avengers age of
ultron
which uh which went over very very well
and after so many years at comic con
what's the what's the coolest moment
you've had this year
i it's got to be that footage playing
it's got to be that that early footage
we've been working for a long time the
movie is not finished filming yet we
finish in about two weeks
and to be able to put footage together
which we've been planning all year and
bring it here and unveil it to people
and have them react like that josh
whedon our writer and director couldn't
be here he's still in london he had he
had a leg injury that prevented him from
being able to fly which was really a
bummer for us because he's been working
on that footage so he said just let me
know how it plays just let me know how
it plays so we played the footage i
turned around and the house lights and
hall h came up and everybody was
standing and i took a picture and said
it right to joss and i said there's your
answer it was a standing ovation so that
that was that means a lot and it means a
lot here which is the place where we
come to unveil everything for the first
time you know not you know for me going
back to early x-men movies and
spider-man movies but for marvel studios
and in the history of the marvel
cinematic universe it started right
there in hall h with iron man 1. last
question ryan h m one of our co-workers
on marvel.com yeah he was on set and he
said he sees everything marvel wise
right he said seeing paul bethany in
that vision costume was one of the
craziest things he's ever seen well
that's uh that's quite a marvel.com
scoop i must say because he we didn't
even
include him in the footage uh yet but
yes he looks unbelievably cool even
before uh even before he's he's soaring
through the sky and this guy
sometimes he's going very fast
sometimes he's very slow he takes him
out he stops remarkable so thank you
thanks very much thank you so much thank
you thank you
marvel
your universe